All right. So I'm sitting here
with, with Dr. Jordan Peterson.
We were going to talk about the
weird overlap between our books.
There's a sort of metal fiction aspect
of it because Jordan had written the
rules for, it was a Cora entry, right? It
started to rules in Ancora. That's right.
42 roles got pared down. So there's
going to be like 19 sequels, right?
Keep rolling them out. And um,
and I thought they were amazing.
And so I was writing or fanatics,
I was writing the first book in
the series and an orphan acts.
My main character is an assassin and he
has these sorts of 10 commandments that
are the operational rules for an assassin.
And I wanted something to offset that,
uh, for a kid who's in his life
who lives downstairs from him,
who's being raised as a good
human instead of as an assassin.
And I wanted a set of rules that
were kind of counterbalance that.
And at the time I was reading
Jordan's, uh, rules that he listed.
And so I sort of use those
as a counterbalance is sort
of a positive masculinity
to use to use the horrible phrase,
the weld trodden term,
but to actually show how somebody might
be raised properly instead of as an
international assassin.
And at the time, you know,
you were a mirror professor at u Toronto,
I thought what could possibly
be controversial about
this? Yeah. Right. And so,
so that's how it sort of,
yeah, well it was fun to see,
you know, when you create
something like those rules,
I wrote them for Quora and I had written
like 50 Quora answers and some of them
got disproportionately popular,
which is exactly what you'd expect
because some things get disproportionately
popular and,
and the core rules attracted a lot of
attention by core standards or by the
standards of what I was writing on Quora.
And then you would pick,
you picked him up and I thought it's one
of the things that's very interesting
about doing something creatively
is that you sort of launch it.
Like you launch a note in a bottle on
the ocean and you have no idea where it's
going to end up.
And so that was the first interesting
manifestation of those rules outside of
the Kora containers, so to
speak. And then of course,
part of our discussion about the rules
also led to their encapsulation in 12
rules for life.
And that was much later.
And it's been interesting to see how
that overlap has developed as well.
Well it's also weird to see what
connects, like, it's so funny with,
with orphan acts when
I was first adapting.
And the big thing with that is that
my character kind of interacts.
He's an archetypal character,
like a Jack reacher Jason Bourne,
but lives in the real world with you
and me. You know, so it's like he's not,
you never see James Bond go home.
Just what an architectural
character should do. Right.
It should exist in abstraction and
also be embedded in the real world.
Yeah.
But usually you have like the high
plains drifter who's like all feeding his
horse and like moving on to the next town.
So I thought it'd be so fun to have
them like interacting with the annoying
Jewish woman who lives upstairs and
having an awkward confrontation with the
woman who lives downstairs
who has chemistry with.
So it's an archetypal character
wrestled into the real world.
That's what the Spiderman
people did really well.
The marvel when exactly ended Spiderman
that extraordinarily well.
He has to like re stitch is Costa.
But no one thought about that,
you know,
and he's like late for school and
all those problems. Exactly, exactly.
So that was, that was
sort of the motif. Um,
well that is also the problem of,
of it's,
it's a more complex
psychological problem of,
of integrating the archetipal with the
real world because there's an element of
everyone's psyche that's, that's
transpersonal. That's archetipal right?
Because to some degree you should manifest
the mythological hero in your life,
but the critical issue there
is in your life, right?
Because your life is like your
life is like the, the bottle that,
or the lamp that the genie is in.
It's like the genie is God
for all intents and purposes,
but it's in this little tiny container.
It's like,
well that's what you're like because
you have this archetipal element to your
personality, which is your
capacity for heroic endeavor,
but it's all constrained
by the hypothetical or the
trivialities of your life.
And you have to have to
mediate between those.
Well, and that's the weird
thing. Like you were saying,
one of the things when you write is
you don't always know what's going to
connect. Right? You never knew that
those rules would become, you know,
number one bestselling book
everywhere in the world.
What was so interesting is there's this
one scene at the opening of orphan acts
where he's in the elevator
and he's got a cut on his arm.
We don't know what it's from,
and he has to fake to kind of pass as
a real person among all the people.
And he's kind of covering it up.
But he's got suppressors and he
used the SOC as a tourniquet.
So he's missing a sock and he's kind of
trying to pass his secret identity among
other people that seen connected
unbelievably with readers with.
And it would, it would be like the
last scene that I would have thought.
And when I adapted the book initially
for Bradley Cooper as a feature,
and I remember I was like,
well if I have Bradley Cooper,
let me open with some big
action is show off offy thing.
And both his production company and
the head of the studio were like,
we need the elevator saying like this
elevator scene became the iconic thing.
Of course.
Cause it does what you're talking.
There shouldn't be some music playing in
the back of the exactly. Like there is.
Yeah.
So from Ipanema there's something awful
if you get caught between the mirror and
in New York City. Right, right.
But it's weird because I never would've
thought that would be the thing.
So the stuff that you send out,
do you have any idea why that
was so attractive to people?
Well,
I think it's exactly,
the thing that we were talking about is
like you don't see James Bond in that
circumstance. It's so it's like
this archetype guy has a mission,
is a knife cut that he
tourniquets is armed with.
And then he's in the elevator that you
and I have been in and everyone's nagging
him that he's missed the Hoa meeting,
the Homeowner's association meeting
where they're voting on like the new
carpeting in the lobby and he's just
trying to get out of it and he's covering.
So there's this wish fulfillment
fantasy aspect to it,
but it's almost like our own lives and
like everyone knows what it's like to be
dealing with annoyances and logistics,
but then he gets to go back to his life
is like a super secret assassin who
helps the helper.
Well, there's another element of it too,
I would say, which is that, that, that,
that scene and,
and that,
that context also suggests
that one of the ways that you,
one of the things that you have to do
in order to put up with those mundane
daily elements of life is also to have
your adventure along with you. Right.
So,
and I mean,
one of the things that I've been talking
to my audiences about continually is
that you need to have a meaning in your
life that's of sufficient grandier let's
say,
or a sufficient power so that the petty
sufferings of life become not only
justifiable, but acceptable
in the broader context and so,
and sufficient risk and sufficient risk.
Because while that and that,
and that's what puts the
adventure into it, right?
It's like in the elevator scene,
it's,
it's not only that everyone
can relate to the mundane,
it's also that everyone can see that
what transcends the mundane is also
fundamentally necessary because otherwise
you are nothing but a collection of
trivialities and,
and life has so much suffering that if
you're just a collection of trivialities,
you're not going to be able to bear it.
So you need your heroic adventure,
which is what's animating you.
Literally Anima is the soul, right?
That's what Adam a means.
So that's literally animating you while
you have to put up with being trapped in
this little tiny fire.
I thought about this a lot
when I was writing Batman.
I wrote Batman for two years for DC and
I was fascinated by the sort of seesaw
tilt between perfection and intimacy,
which is so Batman, you know,
he doesn't have a magic ring,
he can't fly.
He just represents the pinnacle of
human discipline and achievement.
It's because his parents died when he was
young, right? He's alone in Wayne Manor.
There's, Robin always dies, there's always
a Robin and he dies. He's a playboy.
He doesn't have anyone intimate.
And if there's no one in your life,
you can maintain perfection.
But the more you inch into intimacy,
a dog, a spouse, a partner, children,
the more that you get
this sort of conflict and
complication that starts to take
over and detract from that
version of perfection.
So it's like you can be
perfect without intimacy,
but then you're not perfect
cause you have no intimacy.
And so the more that you integrated,
it's almost like the more that you're
accepting the realities of life.
And there's also,
I think it's also one of the things
that's interesting in the Batman reference
because one of the things you
see in the Batman Joker dynamic,
especially the one with
Heath Heath Ledger,
was the joker was always pushing at
Batman because of the evil of his
perfections. Like you're this far away
from me. And that perfectionistic drive,
there's something totalitarian
and single minded about it, right?
And then it's the encapsulation of that
in intimacy that that humanizes it and
produce it sane. Right? And so, so that
unit, dimensional perfection can go very,
very badly when it goes.
And to be contextually constrained like
that is actually like a definition of
sanity.
It's something that young talked about
when he was commenting on nature and
people liked nature.
I said he believed that nature would
have been able to maintain his sanity for
much longer,
assuming no physiological degeneration
had he been able to incorporate himself
within a profession and a family.
That's your nailed them to the
earth and inhale way stilts down.
And that's right.
That's exactly right.
So I thought we'd just talk briefly
about the editing process for 12 roles.
It was a lot of fun because I got to read
it all early, which was, which was fun.
So I had it featured in the orphan x
books like two years before it came out.
Right.
Which is why I always like to remind
you that I'm mostly responsible for your
six hours.
I do appreciate that a lot. Well,
I sent all the chapters to Greg.
I had an editor at Penguin, Craig
Piot, who was very, very helpful.
So I had two editors really,
and other people commenting on it.
But I sent each chapter to Greg and
he would just shred them. He's really,
really good at that and
well and very comical.
And so he'd just be absolutely brutal.
It is criticisms,
but it was also also always
extremely funny. Yeah. Well,
and then I was also absolutely staggered
by how rapidly you could do that and,
and to point to what was working in,
to tell me what was working.
And so that was exceptionally helpful
in your very, very skilled at that. So,
so there's the compliment
you're gonna get from me.
No, it was, it was, it was very
helpful. Now the insult first you lead,
you softened me up with a
compliment and now you know,
but I think what was helpful is,
so,
I mean I took three courses
from you as an undergraduate.
So it's like we've been swimming
in the same waters for a long time.
So it was really interesting for me
to see, you know, through the process.
Um, you know, I have a,
I have a sense that goes kind of all
the way down of the ideas you're running
with going back to before maps of meaning,
right?
Going back to the source book articles
and stuff, you lectured amount.
So it was really fun to see them take
hold and move from the abstract into the
ever more accessible.
And
the setback was useful too because you're,
you're,
you've developed this intense skill in,
in producing commercial widely,
publicly accessible fiction and,
and you have a sense of what
works in terms of narrative flow.
And that was very useful to have
that perspective on the way the, the,
the stories were laid out in,
in each of the rules to make them,
to give them that narrative punch,
which is necessary to add an additional
dimension of, what would you say?
Quality to the writing.
It's helpful. I'm glad, but it's, it's
good working with someone with like,
your learning curve was like this.
So it was like the first one
that we went through, you know,
if there was something that has the speed
with which you can sort of implement
some white new information and, and
reflect that in writing is unbelievable.
That's fun.
Or there's a benefit of being sort of
experienced in multiple dominant Tarik is
I think because there's so many things
that you've done at such a high level
that when you add a new one,
the learning curve is like this.
So it was also really fun
because it's like, you know,
well, we'll have a chance to
do it again. Yeah. All right.
Expect when I write the next book because
there may be an extension of 12 rules
for life,
I presume.
So it's fun bumping into you here cause
we just bumped into each other at the
studio today.
Yeah, halfway around the world and
one studio apart. But so that's great.
So we'll work on the next one and I'll
work on the next orphaned acts and we'll
go from there.
All right, good to see you, man.